welcome back to killing in knowledge
stats there's actually not that much
killing going on here except my ass just
keep killing me everyone somebody has a
big problem with my alright was just
gonna god I'll trust anyone yeah oh
where oh [ __ ] I hate him hate him so
much
oh [ __ ] I'm just gonna chill out on this
so fire while he passes alright I just
want to thank you both so much for
voting for the king of the web we're in
the lead now yes
wait is it coming here okay we're good I
hear wait where I don't where is he tell
me where the [ __ ] is he
I keep hearing him dead end
where is he Wow
I don't like it hi I'm [ __ ] door
[Music]
nationally duh
oh no notion you're I think I do we are
we're good we're good
also for things to be only the lies from
yesterday I was a lot of fun I'm gonna
upload it to YouTube so don't worry if
you missed it and I will make more stop
oh I'm outta here
I don't like all does that do that
someone clearly wants to become a roofer
ah someone clearly wants to become
homosexual anyway yeah you can get that
joke with the closet no I was no okay
I'll just take this bedroom key now all
right well yeah I don't even know at the
bedroom is this totally looks like a
bedroom this does not look like a
bedroom [ __ ] me where's the bedroom
please tell me someone anyone is it here
it's just I'm a dog bar that is scared
of me that is not a bedroom I not give
34 in circles shut up dog
I'm Ricard I don't know he just keeps
barking it's probably someone outside
don't worry best okay actually I'm kind
of worried embark for hours and it's
literally driving me insane okay maybe
it's here no where is the bed lost
bedroom us I don't think it's any of
these rooms are police where is the
bedroom huh you tell me oh it's here why
don't you tell on you lie to me while I
mean my margin lie to mean that wine
I got data collection bedroom a bedroom
where's the bedroom where's better man
hey this could be a bedroom and are you
a bedroom no that's not a bedroom
are you a bedroom tell me every [ __ ]
room is locked la da da library [ __ ]
room it's [ __ ] logs what should we do
I don't really know but every [ __ ]
room we go over here
the room is opened but it doesn't go any
[ __ ] where I already tried like a
million times let's just go back and see
what we can find
it is the bedroom key is this where the
bedroom is I keep singing but I don't
know why here is Jennifer and she's
looking fine let's just go back let's
just go back he'll get the carpet look
at the pottery look at everything and
just be hi
this is like a bedroom but I didn't need
a key I don't even know why let's look
in the closets maybe there's more gay
people who wants to turn homosexual
that's not the bad room either oh I'm
just gonna go I'm just gonna go I'm just
gonna go I don't even know anyone I
don't even know any my what the hell
okay okay oh yeah oh my god
don't turn around first rule of amnesia
I just [ __ ] broke it I think I broke
my throat ooh that's scary I don't like
that
I know seniority does no nothing your
dose of left don't notice why would he
just taste me I didn't do anything okay
this way was it no was it this way yes I
don't think I can sing anymore
god damn it look at the Statue look at
the pot real look at the copper look at
freakin everything look at my penis look
at that guy's [ __ ] look at my vagina
what the hell did I just say yeah let's
go here Oh [ __ ] doors man all right
dance on table dance on the table that's
on the table yeah yeah yeah yeah
standing on the fireplace everyday
[ __ ] say everyday what the hell is
there something here the players tell me
I don't like when they hide the keys in
different places all right bruh senores
maybe it's synergy for every doesn't
even go anywhere no comprendo Senor el
as engineer it does okay still there
this is exactly totally like that yeah
I'll get that up here and I don't trust
your brother either double-killed
[ __ ] looking going anyway what the
hell this place is bigger this place is
huge
goddamn castles goddamn while you
castles alright so left right we got to
do that let's make it cozy first I don't
have any tinderboxes what am I talking
about Oh little it off king kelana cough
cough Ilana Bing Kabbalah all a doula
DAF attempt at unpaved path poof do for
and no yeah alright let's see if we can
get a double kick freaking fireplace
double kill now I got damn
like pee what is this what is this
stupid [ __ ] burn all right apparently
you're supposed I don't chest I can't go
anywhere
are you [ __ ] kidding me I did a
little dove in vain
oh I'm exhausted now I'm exhausted
come on I did the Ola dueling vain god
dammit
alright let's go here then just because
the statues are not my cup of tea please
let they mean speed the bedroom study
all my [ __ ] papers oh it work the key
totally work alright
I feel good about I mean I feel really
good about if you know what I mean I
don't feel good I'm just kidding I feel
horrible [ __ ] library since when are
books haunting tell me perks are not
supposed to kill people guess only of
boredom if you know what I mean brim
punch alright miss Chae I need you over
here hey what are you doing stop humping
my table is my friend all right what do
you need to help with all you need to
get there you're very smart man P you're
a very clever man Thank You mr. chef hey
I totally see this [ __ ] move how do I a
god dammit I don't have my Hemans power
charged up I have to wait or maybe
perhaps find the lever somewhere
I don't like this should I jump down
there I can't go to fat [ __ ] being too
fat it sucks
everyone pokes you I don't like it
alright we didn't go here did we hey I
found it
I didn't work or you did it is there
more of them
maybe there's a certain order to them
well maybe it's just there for a fail
what is it doing there
I have to pump [ __ ] like a penis no
don't be like a penis no it's in yours
god damn it I gotta pump it like a penis
I don't like fumbling a penis pump that
[ __ ] pump it louder pump it louder
charge in charge in charge in charge
charge in charge in no not senoritas
hey what is this doing it Vincent the
owner of the in fail again he killed 30
people now god damn it why does that
only keep killing people he isn't stupid
he was before he was a mistake to waste
those lives to finding a potion for me
and leave it was a mistake to engage him
for the job people are taking about
talking about it and now that something
isn't right there I quit this sin like
get it oh and I would remember this
story
totally got an off track with this story
all right bro so let's do some epic MLG
work chef climbing no got damaged mister
share cooperate ok pity I will do
anything don't worry I'm on your side
not on the power side totally not on the
barrel side buddy what he's ain't
nothing
go there where Estus thing we're looking
for
jump MLG [ __ ] and [ __ ] jade god
damn it that was an MLG
jumping down here looking through the
scrolls hello to mr. Sherr hell a pity
hey find another one maybe all of them
needs to go out like your mom's penis
what the [ __ ] that I just say let's just
ignore that I'm sorry okay yeah chop
nice I invented the language who's I was
like god dammit waves you know language
for chopping people I'm so creative it's
ridiculous alright we found another I
chop that [ __ ] let's chop the las Tres
source chop Nasser's what is it
I thought I saw it opening it I hope
there's only three they could have
hinted at many but three is a golden
number we all know that did it do
anything it didn't even cling why you
know cling god damn you for not clinging
you made me disappointed why doesn't
everyone in my entire life have claimed
what the hell am i taking the beach
token bear I don't even know her and
chicken beard
where the hell is that thing that will
make a fling I don't even know I have a
penis where the hell is that thing that
will make things playing yeah why don't
you clean I can't believe we would go
into where Hale had such a bright future
together but then you were like I'm not
gonna cling [ __ ] and then maybe now you
know claying
either that means we haven't found one
that's supposed to cling I'm looking for
the last one that you are you thought
you could hide from me [ __ ] you thought
you could hide from me we need to find
one more apparently got damaged I
already looked through so many [ __ ]
bookcases why do they make me do this I
don't even know anymore did I miss one
perhaps yes did I miss - perhaps yes
probably make sure I get a look good
luck on your little [ __ ] alright
everything y'all - here chaps yes yes I
didn't pity all right I think Seth I
think anyone's gonna talk back to me
okay there's nothing there all right
everything you oughta bex everything and
all the chaps alright right then I'll
just keep on like I found you sons of
[ __ ]
yeah yeah huh alright let's keep going
see you later chaps alright have a nice
day books I love like all right wait got
hey that English knee I can't feel out
my soul just slowly leaves my body I
even thought I had more than 10
alchemists working for me no one found a
potion for me I'm not sure what will
happen when I died there's no hair to
the throne what will happen with my
little principality I can use advanced
words [ __ ] yeah yeah principally
reality principie Prince [ __ ] it
well I shouldn't waste my last time with
thinking about things like May I should
just rather help poor people with
shelter and food to make sure that I
would come to heaven no that's totally
not selfish w you son of a [ __ ]
hello I totally found your keto totally
solving this bookshelf puzzle of yours
like a bow you know totally find your
room or what I bought I don't even know
where it goes but
oh oh hey hey hey
[Music]
hello business yeah like you picked up
eat up eat up eat up a star